المنظمه الدوليه للشرطه الجنائيه او
الانتربول يتكون من 195 دوله وكيانا بهدف
دعم اجهزه الشرطه وملاحقه المطلوبين امنيا
حول العالم الانتر بول لا ينفذ عمليات
الاعتقال بنفسه بلديه ادوات وشراط اخطرها
انشره الحمراء وتستخدم لتنسيق بين اجهزه
الشرطه في الدول الاعضاء لمحاربه الجريمه
عام 2021 نشر الانتربول اكثر من 18,000
نشره مختلفه النشره الحمراء تصدرت القائمه
روسيا كانت من اكثر الجنسيات المطلوبه
بتوها من تتعلق بجرائم خطيره من ابرزها
القتل ثم سلفادور والارجنتين والهند
وامريكا غير ان اغلب المطلوبين في
الولايات المتحده ليسو امريكيين التزحوا
من دول المجاوره على راسها المكسيك بتوها
من تتعلق بتهريب المخدرات وجرائم القتل
بالبشر لكن اللافت انه لا وجود لاي دوله
افريقيه في تلك نشرات الصادره عن الانترنت